oui qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est-ce qui fait face et de
muriel ne t'en fais pas
muriel prendre mûrir calme toi tout va
se traduire la chanson c'est vivre nous
qui change son déclin
incroyable c'est une chanson de lino
bien alors ça s'appelle l'interview
alerte aux roses
scheer est ce que vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou es ce que
vous avez besoin de faire l'amour pour
aimer le premier vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour a ses raisons
mais je croyais que je changerais les
hommes ils ont besoin de faire l'amour
pour aimer cher on se concentre adultère
friedrich vous trompe
imaginons vous préférez ne pas savoir où
vous êtes partisan de tout vous dire
rien mais que j'ai bien sûr le droit de
le tuer oh la la la la
est ce que vous préférez un mec qui
baissent très bien mais qui est infidèle
ou un mec qui baisent mal mais qui est
fidèle
j'ai déjà pris des rides y est allé de
deux châssis la première fois qu'on
aurait pensé après muriel c'est vraiment
pour une femme pour s amuser avec un
homme de toute façon donc bien sûr si
c'est pour s'amuser autant à voir
l'homme qui n'est pas fidèle dans ce cas
là je n'aurai pas besoin d'être fidèle
moi même quel est pour vous le lieu
idéal pour une étreinte le lieu idéal
pour le sexe dans une voiture ah bon
pourquoi ce qu'on chasse était dans la
voiture et d élever dans l'amérique
profonde faute à monseigneur dans le
carrosse jamais est-ce que vous avez
scheer ait un fantasme que vous n'avez
pas encore réalisé yann moix je crois
que je dis toujours une idée comme tout
le monde mais encore un truc j'ai pas
osé faire quoi oui tout à fait et vous
garer mais les fantasmes ça va ça vient
ça change tout le temps à autre il faut
vite les réaliser sinon après ça change
de forme
on est d'accord bien alors maintenant
cette question m'a été envoyé par
georges avec un j est ce que vous
préférez
l'amour cinq fois par jour toute votre
vie est quand même homme ou une fois par
mois toute votre vie avait quand même
différent je crois que 5 soit un jeu
[Musique]
bien alors un autre email une question
email d'arnaud si friedrich rate un
rendez vous important
l'après midi et qui vient faire l'amour
avec vous vous lui dit tu es fou où tu
me rend folle et bien dans le futur je
dirais oui bien sûr aux folles je vous
le dirai pas tu es fou yes ouïe ouïe
qu'est ce qui est écrit sur l'ardoisé
vigne fait par l'ardoisé schirrhein et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais 1
pouces bleus